Oh [Music]
the child in my heart rise above what
does it mean to you to have the best of
the best artists come together to sing
your songs to honor you it's pretty
great
I mean we worked hard on getting a lot
of you know yet trying to get the right
people who wanted everybody to be happy
and be able to pick the song they watch
how hard did Miley Cyrus campaign for
landslide she wanted it what do you
think of that moment I'm gonna be yeah
I'm happy I mean and you know you want
the people that want to do the songs to
do it son
you don't want somebody to get stuck
with the song they don't really want to
do so it's fantastic and she does it I
think in her show off and on you've been
so open about the ups and downs of your
career and their life what does it mean
to sort of be here tonight at the Grammy
weekend being honored in this way it's a
great honor it really is a great honor
and you know at our age you know it's
like we're you you stop expecting things
you really do you know because you think
you know your there's so many
generations of music following us up
like you know Miley you know it means a
lot to me I was at Music Harris Tom
Petty last year and so that meant a lot
to me it was the second time I second -
the last time I saw him so this is even
more important to me than it was before
and he really explained what this whole
thing was more than I actually knew so
it's interesting that this would come
our way this year what is next for you
is there tourists there more music
coming well we're not you know we're not
I'm I'm going to Hawaii for two months
because I need a vacation I just did 70
shows so I'm tired yeah
and then I'd I'm not exactly sure what
we're doing but you know it's all it's
all out there so we're all free
[Music]
you